vom 17 bis 24 april 2015 führte die
dritte panzergrenadierbrigade gemeinsam
mit deutschen und tschechischen soldaten
am truppenübungsplatz allentsteig die
multinationalen übung dynamic response
15 durch im scharfen schuss wurden die
einsatzarten angriff und verzögerung
geübt
etwa 1400 soldaten übten darunter waren
350 internationale übungsteilnehmer
neben dem scharfschießen wurde unter
anderem auch eine baum sprengung
durchgeführt diese erschwerte dem gegner
das vorrücken
um die eigene bewegungsfreiheit und die
handlungsfreiheit des kommandanten zu
erweitern wurde von den pionieren eine
übersetzt stelle über den ottensteiner
straße errichtet
das hauptaugenmerk lag beim kampfgruppen
schießen dem höhepunkt der übung
bundesminister magister klug begrüßte
die übungsteilnehmer und würdigte die
bedeutung dieser übung
ich habe mir zum ziel gesetzt bis ende
des jahres ein sogenanntes
kooperationspartner auf die beine zu
stellen indem wir mit gleichgesinnten
armeen unsere zusammenarbeiten
intensivieren werden
gerade so wie es mir die österreichische
sicherheitsstrategie parlamentsbeschluss
auch vorgibt die österreichische armee
hat in diesem zusammenhang besondere
assets einzubringen ich denke gerade an
die bereiche gebirgs ausbildung abc
abwehr und vieles mehr also die
österreichische armee hat etwas
einzubringen und wir werden die
zusammenarbeit mit anderen armeen
intensivieren